"THE FIVE" ."
IF YOU ALREADY THOUGHT THEY
DEMOCRATIC 2020 CANDIDATES WERE
A FRIGHTENED PACK OF COCKTAIL,
GET A LOAD OF BETO, HE IS AS
STURDY AS A GUMMY WORM.
HE FELT HE HAD TO APOLOGIZE OVER
A SICK JOKE HE MADE ABOUT HIS
WIFE.
BEFORE WE PLAY THIS JOE, YOU
MIGHT WANT TO SCOOT THE KIDS OUT
OF THE ROOM.
>> I JUST GOT A CALL FROM MY
WIFE, AMY, BACK IN EL PASO,
TEXAS, WHERE SHE'S RAISING,
SOMETIMES WITH MY HELP, ULYSSES
WHO IS 12 YEARS OLD, MOLLY WHO
IS 10, AND THEIR LITTLE BROTHER
HENRY WHO IS 8 YEARS OLD.
>> Greg: HE APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT.
IN CASE YOU MISSED IT, HE
APOLOGIZED FOR "SOMETIMES WITH
MY HELP," HE APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
HERE'S A QUICK MENTAL EXERCISE.
IMAGINE A GUY APOLOGIZING FOR
THAT EVER BECOMING PRESIDENT.
HE FELT HE HAD TO APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE "PEOPLE WERE OUTRAGED,"
MEANING THREE CRANKS ON TWITTER.
IN THE ERA OF SCALP FIRST, THINK
LATER, HUMOR IS THE FIRST TO GO.
WHEN CNN.com ARTICLE CLAIMS
MANY FEMALE DEMOCRATIC
OPERATIVES WERE ACTIVISTS WERE
TRIGGERED.
FOR ONCE, MEDIA, CAN WE GET A
HEAD COUNT ON "MANY?"
WHAT KIND OF PERSON GETS
OFFENDED OVER THAT.
WOULDN'T THE RIGHT RESPONSE BE
"IT'S A JOKE.
IF YOU CAN TAKE A JOKE, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A REAL PROBLEM
WHEN I BECOME PRESIDENT."
SADLY BETO WENT THE OTHER WAY.
>> I WILL BE MUCH MORE
THOUGHTFUL GOING FORWARD IN THE
WAYS I TALK ABOUT OUR MARRIAGE
AND THE WAY IN WHICH I
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TRUTH OF THE
CRITICISM THAT I HAVE ENJOYED
WHITE PRIVILEGE.
>> Greg: WELCOME TO THE MODERN
LIBERAL MAN, A SNUG E FULL OF
GUILT AND FEAR.
HE THREW IN WHITE PRIVILEGE.
>> THE ONLY WAY TO MEET SOME OF
THESE HISTORIC CHALLENGES IS TO
BE ABLE TO USE THIS ENGINE OF
CAPITALISM.
IT WILL BE GOVERNMENT
INTERVENTIONAL POLICY LOAN THAT
MAKES IT POSSIBLE.
HAVING SAID THAT, IT'S CLEARLY
AN IMPERFECT, UNFAIR, UNJUST AND
RACIST CAPITALIST ECONOMY.
>> Greg: OKAY, NOW TRY OTHER
ECONOMIES, YOU KNOW THE ONES
THAT AREN'T AS AWESOME IN
ERADICATING POVERTY.
OUR RACIST SYSTEM HAS DONE MORE
TO HELP HUMANITY THAN ANY EVER.
BUT WHAT WOULD HE KNOW ABOUT
ECONOMIES?
HE INHERITED AND MARRIED HIS
MONEY, MAKING HIM A PERFECT
LEFTY, RELYING ON THE WEALTH OF
OTHERS TO SUPPORT HIS SILLY
IDEAS, OVERSIZED EGO AND ABSURD
HAND GESTURES.
JUAN, YOU AND I SIT HERE AND
WE'VE MADE COMMENTS ABOUT BEING
MARRIED, RIGHT?
WE'VE MADE JOKES ABOUT WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO BE MARRIED, FOR YOU A
LONG TIME, FOR ME NOT SO LONG.
HE APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
>> Juan: I THOUGHT IT WAS
WEAK, UNNECESSARY.
I AM A BIG BOOSTER OF FATHERS
AND SO I DO THINK IF THE IDEA IS
THAT YOU'VE GOT TO BE INVOLVED,
YOU CAN'T JUST BE ON THE RODENTS
AND MAKING MONEY.
I'M BRINGING IN THE BREAD, SO
BABY, YOU TAKE CARE OF THE KIDS.
THAT'S OUT OF LINE BUT I'M A BIG
BOOSTER OF FATHERHOOD.
I THINK WE ARE SEEN ON THE LEFT
IS A REACTION WHICH IS THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY'VE GOT TO SOMEHOW
CONFORM, ESPECIALLY IN A TIME
WHEN A SLIGHT SLIPUP CAN MAKE
BIG NEWS AND KNOCK YOU OUT OF
THE RACE.
TO MY MIND, IF THIS IS ABOUT
TRUMP GOING AFTER HIS HAND
GESTURES, PEOPLE SAYING THAT HE
IS PC AND A SNOWFLAKE,
REPUBLICANS, WAKE UP.
HE JUST RAISED $600 MILLION.
>> Greg: 600?
>> Juan: 6 MILLION.
I WAS THINKING IN TERMS OF HOW
HE BEAT BERNIE SANDERS.
HE'S WAY AHEAD OF AMY KLOBUCHAR
WHO WAS ALSO RAISED SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNTS OF MONEY, AND EVEN
FARTHER AHEAD OF ELIZABETH
WARREN.
TO ME, RAISING THIS MONEY WAS A
SURPRISE BECAUSE I DIDN'T KNOW
-- I KNEW HE HAD RAISED
80 MILLION IN THE TEXAS RACE
AGAINST TED CRUZ AND I THINK YOU
WROTE THAT OFF AS TED CRUZ BEING
A LESS THAN GREAT CANDIDATE.
BUT THIS IS AGAINST FELLOW
DEMOCRATS AND PEOPLE SAY WE
DON'T KNOW HIM.
WE DON'T KNOW HIS POSITION.
DEMOCRATS LIKE THIS GUY.
HE IS REAL ENERGY, AND YOU'RE
SEEING SOME OBAMA PEOPLE NOW
FLOCK TO HIS CAMPAIGN.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW, DANA.
WOMEN WERE UPSET BECAUSE THEY
COULDN'T MAKE THAT JOKE.
DO YOU ACTUALLY BELIEVE PEOPLE
ARE SINCERELY OUTRAGED?
>> Dana: I HAVE MADE THE JOKE
IN REVERSE.
IT'S NOT A CHILD.
I POST THESE GREAT PICTURES OF
JASPER ON INSTAGRAM.
I WROTE A BOOK ABOUT JASPER.
WHO TAKES CARE OF JASPER?
IT'S NOT ME.
IT'S PETER.
AND I WILL NOT APOLOGIZE.
>> Greg: A STAY-AT-HOME DOG
OWNER.
YOU ARE THE YOKO.
HE IS THE JOHN.
>> Dana: EXACTLY.
HE WORKS FROM HOME.
THERE WAS A LOT OF PEOPLE SAYING
IT'S A BAD ROLLOUT BECAUSE BETO
HAD TO APOLOGIZE.
ARGUED LEAK KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND
HAD A WORSE ROLLOUT.
NO ONE IS TALKING ABOUT IT.
>> Greg: JESSE, I THINK HE IS
STEALING "I AM WATERS, THIS IS
MY WORLD."
>> Jesse: AS A GUY WHO LIKES
HAND GESTURES, I HAVE TO MARVEL
AT SOME OF THESE.
THEN THERE'S THE OTHER ONE,
TALKING ABOUT AMY, HE GOES AMY.
AMY.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THAT
REPRESENTS.
I ALSO DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY HE
APOLOGIZED.
HE WAS PRAISING AMY.
WHAT IS HE SUPPOSED TO DO?
HE IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
HE NEEDS TO GET OUT OUTSIDE OF
HIS HOUSE TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
IS HE GOING TO TAKE THE KIDS OUT
OF EL PASO AND PUT THEM IN
SCHOOL IN IOWA?
SO THAT HE CAN COPARENT IN IOWA.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
HE IS LIKE GUMBY.
I DON'T LIKE THE WHITE PRIVILEGE
COMMENT.
I REALIZE AS A WHITE MAN I
PROBABLY HAVE PRIVILEGES I DON'T
EVEN KNOW I HAVE BUT TO SAY THAT
REESE IS DETERMINATIVE OF
SUCCESS IS UNFAIR TO ALL THE
OTHER THINGS.
TO POINT AND LOOK AT HIS
SUCCESSFUL WHITE PERSON AND SAY
HE GOT THAT BECAUSE HE'S WHITE
AND DISCOUNTS THE HARD WORK THAT
GOT THERE.
>> Greg: HE HAS A DIFFERENT
KIND OF PRIVILEGE.
RICH PARENTS ON A RICH WIFE.
IT'S PRETTY GOOD PRIVILEGE.
>> Emily: I AGREE.
BEWARE IF HE ASSUMES THAT OFFICE
FOR SOMEONE WHO CAN APOLOGIZE
FOR SOMETHING SO LITTLE.
THE MEDIA IS COVERING FOR HIM.
HE'S RUNNING ON CHARISMA AND
PERSONAL NARRATIVE.
I SEE NONE OF IT.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
SITTING ON THE STORY FOR TWO
YEARS OR WHATEVER, THAT GROUP
THAT HE WAS PART OF, IT WAS A
PRECURSOR TO ANONYMOUS AND HE
SAID I WAS REALLY ON THE MARGINS
AND HIS QUOTE WAS I WANTED TO BE
THE COOL KID.
I WANTED TO BE AS SMART AS THEM.
THAT'S WHAT I SEE THAT HE'S
DOING HERE.
THERE'S NO SUBSTANCE BUT FOR
SOME REASON IT'S SPITBALLING AND
SNOWBALLING AND BERNIE SANDERS
IS JUST A LITTLE BIT BEHIND HIM
SO I DON'T THAT WE SHOULD COUNT
THEM OUT.
HE SHATTERED RECORDS WITH THE
SENATE RACE AND HE STILL DIDN'T
WIN.
>> Greg: APPARENTLY THERE WAS
IN A REPORTER WHO HID AN ARTICLE
ABOUT BETO O'ROURKE UNTIL AFTER
THE SENATE RACE.
HIS EXCUSE WAS HE WAS WRITING A
BOOK WHICH IS KIND OF
INTERESTING.
THEN WE HAVE JOE BIDEN
ACCIDENTALLY ANNOUNCING HE'S
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
ONLY ACCIDENTALLY.
>> THE NEW LEFT.
I'M THE MOST -- I HAVE THE MOST
PROGRESSIVE RECORD OF ANYBODY
RUNNING -- ANYBODY WHO WOULD RU
RUN.
I DIDN'T MEAN...
ANYBODY WHO WOULD RUN.
>> Greg: WHY IS HE WAITING?
>> Jesse: PRETTY SOFT.
I HAVE TO DEFEND JOE.
I THINK WHAT HE WAS SAYING IN
THE UNITED STATES SENATE BECAUSE
HE'S BEEN RUNNING FOR THE SENATE
FOR THREE DECADES.
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS.
>> Juan: HE'S RUNNING.
IT'S A FOREGONE CONCLUSION.
I THINK HE HAS THE LUXURY OF
TAKING HIS TIME, SO DON'T WORRY
ABOUT THAT WITH JOE.
THE BIGGER ISSUE FOR HIM IS, AND
THIS COMES BACK TO SOMETHING WE
TOUCHED ON ABOUT BETO, WHITE
PRIVILEGE AND THE LIKE, IS HE
GOING TO BE VIEWED AS AN OLDER
WHITE MALE OR CAN HE CATCH UP?
I THINK MOST DEMOCRATS
ESPECIALLY IN IOWA JUST WANT
SOMEONE WHO CAN BEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
YOU ARE POINT ABOUT BETO'S
COMMENT ABOUT PRIVILEGED WHITE
MALES, YOU GO BACK AND LOOK AT
AMERICAN HISTORY.
LOOK AT REAL ESTATE, SEGREGATED
NEIGHBORHOODS, HOW WEALTH IS
BUILT, THE NEW DEAL AND WHO GOT
EXCLUDED FROM THE NEW DEAL.
TYPICALLY AGRICULTURE WORKERS,
PEOPLE, BLACK PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: I WOULD AGREE BUT I
ALSO WOULD SAY THERE'S A LOT OF
POOR WHITE WORKING-CLASS PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY TO LOOK AROUND
AND SAY "WHAT PRIVILEGE?"
>> Juan: RIGHT, BUT THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT THE HISTORICAL
DISADVANTAGE OF BEING BLACK THAT
COMPOUNDS WHATEVER DISADVANTAGE
THERE WAS FOR POOR WHITES.
>> Greg: THEN YOU HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE SOLUTION IS